[Music]
2023 a year that many are facing with
trepidation and whilst much of the world
will be tightening its belt there are
plenty of ways in which 2023 is set to
challenge assumptions from antique
treasures and old-fashioned solutions to
psychedelic Revelations
and the fate of the world's biggest
population
here are five stories that may just
transform the world ahead
[Music]
in 2023 the most populous country on the
planet will no longer be China but India
China's population is peaking while
India's has continued to grow
and the UN predicts that on April the
14th 2023 India's population will
overtake that of China's
that is hugely significant in symbolic
terms but what's more important is the
composition of the Indian population
specifically the size of its working age
population
India has more people of working age
than any other population group when
this happens it can lead to what's known
as a demographic dividend because of the
opportunity it offers for economic
growth particularly for developing
countries
take what happened in China a population
boom under Mao was followed by the
introduction of the one child policy in
1979.
this created a big working age
population with fewer children to raise
providing the Manpower for China's
extraordinary economic expansion
India's demographic bulge started much
later than China's in the 2010s
its forecast to continue to around 2050.
with the biggest growth in the next
decade
[Music]
is on this opportunity
a bigger working age population in
theory should mean greater productivity
but in India there are obstacles to its
success
for a start about 90 percent of jobs in
India are informal which means the vast
majority of workers don't have a regular
salary
informal sector workers are quite
productive the problem is that these are
very insecure jobs and so we knew things
like kovid happened suddenly many of
these workers are out of work so Indian
government has been trying to set up
some national pension schemes health
insurance benefits and so on but Social
Security benefits are quite limited for
many of these workers
what's more just 20 percent of women of
working age are actually working
part of the problem is that while girls
are being educated to a higher level
it's often not high enough to work in
offices
so what for these women in the
regime it's quite difficult to find one
for men of the same education there are
many jobs like truck drivers mobile
phone repairers poster delivery workers
a lot of these occupations are not
really open to women
part of China's rapid economic growth
was due to the foreign company's
factories that were set up there the
Indian government has been trying to
mimic this with a make in India campaign
to entice foreign investment it's had
some success in a big boost to India's
manufacturing sector Apple says that it
plans to make the iPhone 14 in India but
the country's infrastructure and the
state of its Workforce remain a barrier
the proportion of the labor force that
has any formal training is extremely
small around three percent there's very
high level still of malnutrition anemia
and other health issues that means that
a lot of people coming into the labor
force cognitive and physical development
may have been impaired the challenge for
the Indian government is to create the
economic environment to encourage both
domestic and foreign businesses to
create jobs
so that it can reap the rewards of being
the most populous country on the planet
2023 could be the year that party drugs
get closer to being in your
prescriptions
with three different psychedelic drugs
in Phase 3 trials to treat mental health
conditions
MDMA could even be approved to treat
post-traumatic stress disorder in
America
2023 could potentially be a landmark
year for us this could be the first
psychedelic assisted therapy approved by
a regulatory body
in any given year around 12 million
Americans suffer from PTSD and for some
like veteran John lubecky it can last
many years he was a participant in a
phase II trial run by Maps PBC which has
been developing MDMA assisted therapy
since 2004.
you're experience me it's kind of weird
various periods of my life
the treatment combines three doses of
MDMA followed by Psychotherapy sessions
it's not just the MDMA it's not just the
therapy it's the two of them working
together the results of our first
pivotal phase three study thought at 67
percent of the people in the MDMA group
no longer met the criteria for having
PTSD
fmdma does get approved for PTSD in 2023
it will be again for patients who really
have limited options at the moment for
treating this very difficult and this
terrible condition
psychedelics like MDMA can make therapy
much more effective they can dampen
activity in the part of the brain that
processes fear and release feel-good
hormones and neurotransmitters like
serotonin
which help reduce anxiety and increase
empathy making it easier for a patient
to reflect on a traumatic experience
psilocybin also known as magic mushrooms
will also be in a phase 3 trial of a
global study for treatment resistant
depression
that also has had a successful trial so
far after having this therapy 12 weeks
later about one in five are in remission
a third drug normally associated with
nightclubs is also in this critical
final stage of testing
ketamine-assisted therapy is showing
promise in helping with alcohol use
disorder in the most recent study 86
percent of patients were still abstained
from alcohol six months after treatment
already offered at awakens private
clinics ketamine could eventually be
regulated for General use in Britain
we're seeing them being hyped as curals
for lots and lots of different mental
health conditions and while I'm really
excited about their promise I do think
it's really important that patients have
realistic expectations about what they
can achieve but all in all I think what
we're looking at is 2023 is going to be
a really pivotal year for psychedelic
medicines
hello I'm Tom standage editor of the
world ahead to read about the prospects
for the coming year in more detail and
get a head start on more of the themes
and Trends to watch take out a
subscription to The Economist which
includes full access to the world ahead
2023 to get the best offer click on the
link and now on with the fill
in 2023 there's one country which could
make a global recession much worse Japan
Japan's the third largest economy and
it's an important economy because its
financial sector is intertwined with the
financial sector of the rest of the
world Japan is the world's biggest
creditor country it holds trillions of
dollars of assets overseas which means
what happens here has the potential to
affect the world's financial markets
in recent years Japan's Central Bank the
bank of Japan has been reassuring a
predictable keeping interest rates low
thanks to its very low inflation
interest rates only have to go up when
inflation Rises and that just hasn't
happened so for a long time Japan defied
any predictions that it would have to
raise interest rates or Titan monetary
policy to the extent that betting that
it would have to do that was a notorious
way to lose money it was a trade called
the Widowmaker it was always wrong even
in the face of the pandemic and the
energy crisis the bank of Japan held
fast thank you
the bank of Japan increasingly an
outlier keeping its overnight interest
rate at minus 0.1 percent the dovish
tone continues oh boy does it ever that
is until now as interest rates have
risen elsewhere in the world Japan has
found itself exposed by the widening Gap
the effect of that has been to make the
Japanese currency the Yen less
attractive to International investors
because if you buy the Yen and invest in
the Japanese bond market you're getting
a lower interest rate lower return than
if you invest in the U.S treasury market
say where you can benefit from those
higher interest rates
as a result the Yen has fallen against
the dollar making Imports more expensive
for Japan which pushed up the rate of
inflation
so at the end of 2022 the bank of Japan
did something unexpected it was all to
do with the interest rate known as the
yield on one particular form of Japanese
government debt its 10-year bond
the yield on this bond is crucial in
Japan because it affects a lot of
economic activity
often borrowing by companies mortgages
and all kinds of contracts are related
to long-term interest rates so the idea
is by keeping those interest rates low
you stimulate spending and growth in the
economy
the Japanese Central Bank has certainly
done that by capping the yield of its
10-year bonds at 0.25 percent
the yield of a long-term Bond moves in
the opposite direction to its price
so in order to keep the cap in place the
bank of Japan has been buying as many
bonds as necessary
but in December 2022 the bank of Japan
increased the cap to 0.5 percent
it might seem a relatively small move
but it was enough to destabilize the
markets Global markets were jolted
overnight after the bank of Japan
unexpectedly widened its cap on 10-year
Japanese government bond yields and it
was also an indication that in 2023 the
bank of Japan might go even further
the question is how much further
it could ditch the cap completely but it
could also start to increase short-term
interest rates too as other central
banks have done already
what's happened in 2022 is that central
banks around the world and most
importantly America's federal reserve
have been raising interest rates and
what that's meant is that there's been a
growing gap between interest rates in
Japan and in the rest of the world
the Federal Reserve for example has
increased interest rates from 0.25
percent at the start of 2022 to 4.5
percent at the end
but if interest rates in Japan climb the
same distance in 2023 it would be much
more concerning
because Japan has the highest level of
public debt of any rich country
while interest rates were low high
public debt was manageable
but if interest rates rise investors
will start to worry that Japan might not
be able to service its debt and start to
sell their bonds causing bond yields to
go up
Suddenly It's going to be more expensive
for companies and for individuals to
borrow if there's a dramatic repricing
in rates that can be quite destabilizing
for the economy and because Japan is so
intertwined with the rest of the world
this destabilization could spread to
other financial markets which means what
the bank of Japan chooses to do in 2023
could make any Global recession much
worse
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it'll be back to the future for the
fashion industry as make do and mend
we'll be back on trend
big clothing brands won't just be
selling new clothes but perhaps
surprisingly also encouraging more wear
out of old items too
Tommy Hilfiger Hugo Boss and lvmh the
world's biggest luxury group are all set
to launch their own repair and resale
services
in 2023 it will all be part of a wider
push towards a more eco-friendly fashion
industry
today we are making more clothes than
ever before but we're using them less
pretty much the entire fashion industry
operates under the same model increasing
throughput and number of Seasons very
very limited clothing is actually
designed to be remade repaired reused or
recycled
every second the equivalent of a rubbish
truck of textiles is burnt or buried in
landfill
one way to eliminate waste and pollution
is through what is known as a circular
economy essentially keeping products in
use for longer
[Music]
save your wardrobe is a new digital
business that has spotted an opportunity
to do just that it buttons up so tight
that we're going to make it a cropped
jacket so it's going to just above the
pockets
growing up in Tunisia I was really
passionate about seeing how local
tailors were able super fast to create
new things or repair things and coming
to Europe I realized that it was all
replaced by fast behaviors of purchasing
I thought let's explore this opportunity
using the app customers can transform
their worn out wardrobes everything
about severe wardrobe started because I
loved seeing things remade again and
again
our recent research shows that things
like circular business models like
resale rental repair and remaking have
the possibility to be 23 of the global
fashion industry by 2030 which
represents a market opportunity of 700
billion US dollars
[Music]
but there is a risk to all this Brands
could use repair services as green
washing without actually helping the
planet
if an organization is offering a service
like repair but to use that service
they'll give you a voucher off their
traditional linear sales this is
incentivizing growth of their linear
business model rather than actually
mainstream transition to a circular
economy for that business any claims
that organizations are making should be
really specific and should have very
clear definitions attached
thank you
on May the 6th 2023 Charles III will be
crowned King of the United Kingdom
while all eyes will be on him some may
glance at his wife Camilla and
especially what she chooses to wear on
her head it's said that he wants queen
Camilla to wear the crown that his
grandmother wore at her coronation in
1937.
at the center of that Crown sits the
Kohinoor diamond
which was taken from India in 1849
was presented to Queen Victoria but the
idea that this was any real way a gift
very much in dispute if she wears it one
expert has said that for Indians this
would be a massive diplomatic grenade in
2023 the Crown's Colonial passed will
add fuel to broader debate over the
repatriation of artifacts taken from
other countries the movement in favor of
restitution is becoming increasingly
strong people should be allowed to see
the art of their own countries in their
own countries Glasgow life museums will
be the first in Britain to return
artifacts to India
all seven objects will be going back to
New Delhi and they have a museum which
is devoted to the display of confiscated
or returned artifacts
our aspiration is to develop strong
contemporary Partnerships across the
world we don't think that's possible if
we continue to retain objects to which
we don't have legal or or moral title
and so part of the process is to address
some of these these These past mistakes
and to to rectify them
the Indian artifacts aren't the only
items being sent home
Glasgow is also returning Benin bronzes
part of a wider campaign to repatriate
these artifacts to what is now Nigeria
the national commission for Museum and
monuments of Nigeria are acting on
behalf of the Uber of Benin they're
trying to build a facility to house all
of the returning bronzers
thousands of bronzers were looted from
Benin City when British troops invaded
in 1897.
is an artist who is part of the campaign
to repatriate them to Nigeria
collectively
the Formby Encyclopedia of our history
of our culture so in taking them away
and locking them involved in various
museums all over the world except in
Africa it creates a void we can't access
as a people the truths which our
ancestors have encoded
other collections in Britain and around
the world have also approved returning
bronzes
but restitution remains a controversial
subject the objects may be seen is just
simply walk some art and therefore why
is there a need to return them but their
spiritual and cultural significance is
uh often way more important and if one
recognizes that then the return of the
object becomes an obvious step to take
there are numerous items in museums
across the world that are wanted back by
their country of origin
among the most infamous are the
Parthenon marbles many of which have
been on display in the British museum
for two centuries
a Greek newspaper has revealed the
museum has been in talks about their
possible return but there are many legal
barriers to restitution often making it
a political decision rather than one
solely for the museum trustees which
means it remains to be seen whether the
Parthenon marbles the Indian Kohinoor
diamond or indeed any other artifacts
might make their way home
2023 is going to be a huge year for this
expect movement on requests from Egypt
from Ethiopia from Ghana from the
Pacific Islands from Easter Island from
Latin America for things to be returned
this is not going to stop here
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage of what might be coming in
2023 click the link and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]